hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
hi there reject nation I'm Tara Erickson
Hera Erickson and I are gonna watch the
video from what culture today called
twelve insanely subtle CGI movie moments
nobody ever noticed oh well hot damn
mess it that's the longest time I ever
heard of a real mountain you think they
thought that through I think they did
video has over 1.5 million views I think
they've been alright already
alright guys we'll watch this video now
let's watch it make sure to follow Tara
online follow me follow me and don't
talk like that all the time I talk like
this so glad we have a four year old
demographic here to entertain when you
watch some finishing touches to an
already splendid see the greatest uses
of the technique by their own nature
Shay I really cried upon these bodies
we'll see you around that well Jared up
men's columns yeah I heard about this
jeremy renner broke both of his arms
while performing his stunts in which he
had to ride a stack of chairs down to
the floor ironically despite being an
Avenger the movie he injured himself in
is a relatively benign comedy go finger
after the actor went to the hospital
received some cast when his arms he
returned to set to complete the scene
that was this movie features a memorable
cameo from Ronald Roldan would assume is
an incredibly oh my god I don't like it
refused that's crazy
while the changes body the removal of
several product tattoos layout both of
our contents of some of these tattoos
cage couldn't help but notice the irony
being quoted as saying I've got a flame
scar on my arm and I'm covering it up to
play the part of a flame that is ironic
with CGI Wow crazy degrees with an
extremely powerful distant
during the that wasn't real CGI shots
used to extend the see haven street sets
due to the strict building regulations
for the Seaside Florida sets the
production could only create shale
buildings first subscriber feet tall and
so a complex of VFX process at least for
the time was used to add additional
terms my goodness
and even once you know the results are
so really believable you're probably
struggle to remember those Martin
Scorsese is a venerated king of old
guard filmmaking his more recent movies
actually employed far more CGI that
you're so CGI the wolf of Wall Street
well let's play to anyone with a
functionally paralyzed that he used
green screen tech for the story yacht
accident sequence elsewhere he utilized
complex visual effects to create my
lonely photo realistic settings whoa
unless you're really really looking for
it holy Charlie its own beach landscapes
to a lion composited into Jordan Wow
most impressively a sweeping crane shots
of a prison courtyard comprised
this is so crazy of course the effect
was actually created in post-production
on set until the digital post that's
currently straight forward split-screen
blending was used to combine separate
takes featuring both twins and yes
pretty much flawless across the entire
film
unless you knew number two
yeah Jackman stunt double Logan it's no
secret that's as gritty as Logan was
Hugh Jackman battles a clone of himself
it's fantastically executed and close to
seamless apart from the audience's
obvious knowledge that it's a trick but
elsewhere there are some decidedly
sneakier effects used to place Jackman
directly in the path of the action when
Logan is caught in a car chase with his
men how do you know this because I went
to where they did not have the technical
possibilities of filming a race on some
digital assistants must
that's a great that was great it was
like super surprising Wow getting there
that's crazy that's a really
entertaining video I every time I start
to talk I wonder if I could just have a
CGI or just follow me around all day oh
yeah much better right put a bunch of
put you put you put your brush right now
I can't talk I'm sorry thanks Greg yeah
just being constant around like a bunch
of hot ladies entourage right yeah we
love him come follow Greg we oh yeah if
I get yes you'd want them all to be dead
within five minutes I love them all to
be like triplets like just so fine yeah
just a bunch of the same woman so like
nine women but triplet triplet nine
women so just like three three different
women x mi three yeah I get it I know it
I know it serious point right yeah
serious let's do it go in do it but um
okay I know a few makeup artists I've
met a couple of visual effects artists
recently with the Oscars one of the big
upsets was that infinity war did not win
for its visual effects of CGI and
everything instead it went to first man
the thing that I've heard across the
board of this video is the master at
demonstrating it oftentimes was actually
harder to create is not a fantasy world
it's actually trying to replicate
something that's very real yeah that's
more challenging because the audience's
association they can much easier
determine like that's fake that's not
real right because like there's a lot of
creative and imagination that goes into
something like infinity war but
something like with first man which won
the Oscar that has to replicate
something that a lot of people have
actually seen on like televised
broadcast never leave you can see
documentaries you can see what's real
and in this example of the 12 that's the
whole thing they're going for real a lot
of these aren't like it's adding a third
story to a building yeah there's like
there are cgi moments at here that I
just had no
clue that they would CJ like Fear and
Loathing in Las Vegas right it was the
90s movie there's so many close-ups I'm
Tobey Maguire and that scene am like
what the hell that was CGI I had no idea
that they think that makes you realize
how for granted you take you know yes
people were always there cop yeah I
beeps over there was the CGI people
people people let's see what they're
doing cuz we're always complaining about
CGI especially in this film community on
YouTube you know overuse of CGI here but
then it's like you watch movies like
wolf of wallstreet Fear and Loathing in
Las Vegas zodiac we just have no idea
the same and she's like one car place
and they're walking and the rest of it
is all on a blue screen he'd swear that
he just shot that on the streets of San
Fran you watch that film it says that
it's true that's a period piece it's in
the 70s so or sixties one of the I
forget which one because of the time
print takes place and they had to alter
some stuff and for a director like David
Fincher who's very meticulous very anal
about every single detail of his films
and his framing a lot of people would
have just shot so freaking anal about it
that he had to have as much realism as
possible or even like wolf of Wall
Street man all those buildings it
impresses me more when you just would
never have guessed that CGI was involved
most of that were like oh that's good
CGI because you know what CGI because
you know it is that one didn't notice
the one in the dark night that was
pretty rad I did kind of think that
maybe they shut down in LA Street and
they actually did turn that car that
around the big truck just flipped it
they're more talking about the realistic
way that it flips like doctor yeah
that's awesome
they had to make it look like it was
Batman's cables like right that did it I
mean a lot of times it's easy I it's
like you're subtly having a CGI out you
know wires on stuntmen and stuff like
yeah as a matter of fact in the matrix
there's a scene in the train before neo
flips off of the trough or the train
tracks unless Agent Smith get hit by a
train if you slow it down you can see
the Sun Devil of Keanu Reeves or it is
gone as I figure yeah you can see him
holding on to the wires
really you actually make out the wires
for it that's what good CGI artists are
for yeah for movies crazy of CGI his the
matrix it's a
we got a surprise they bailed on that
part to take up some water
groundbreaking CGI that movie has they
actually messed up there you are you've
got a couple wires got a couple wires
here movies ruin for me also just
putting Hugh Jackman's face on another
dude insanity
like that's movement that's like crazy
moving bouncing around the car is like
moving that means like every somebody
had to be like 1.5 seconds move like
yeah that's a crazy moving chakras are
just not double and they're doing a car
chase and to actually put your fades it
makes me wonder how that like Will Smith
Jeannie [ __ ] when I was talking about
John about this have you seen that me
footage of Will Smith as a genie
I haven't oh man you're missing out
there it looks great shucks I need to
watch it looks so oh man it looks so
good I'm yeah I know what that word
means yeah do you oh yeah it's he's
pretending it's a plant it's good I ate
of the CSIs meal today yes I'm using it
right that that meal had the joke on you
buddy
yeah Wow we should move on from my big
words and go back to your small ones huh
yeah yeah so big Lee haha I'm just gonna
play it for terror really quick it's
like a split second all right
[Music]
yeah I don't like it doesn't it looks
weird I don't like it I wanted to really
like it hey he looks creepy okay the
issue I have with it it looks like they
just CGI blued Will Smith yeah as
opposed to you should have just
committed to your full transformation
and you don't have to have him look like
Will Smith right just commit to it do
your little like what they do with Annie
surrogates olives movies or Josh for all
understand house this make him look like
a different dude yeah cuz there's gonna
be scenes in the movie where he looks
like Will Smith like the genies in human
form so for this moment he doesn't look
like Will Smith this looks like freaking
creepy terrified and if they're able to
do all these countless like awesome CGI
stuff you could have done something much
better with Disney money and all that
pair tie up why is the word back and he
has this like weird floating it looks
like they superimposed Will Smith's face
on some for someone else so weird
I mean granted that's not supposed to be
subtle CGI but still on also last thing
we own the night yeah I went to a
pre-screening of this like one of those
the screenings it's like a year in
advance oh yeah and that chase scene
there were like scenes it's where
there's no rain with you here rain sound
effects other standing outside you're
like there's no rainy it was a weird
pre-screening because like none of it
was really complete anyway what culture
great job on this video you guys are
some sexy mofos go subscribing them
right away subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification bell
era is on YouTube follow her right away
thank you guys for watching me this is
wrong
oh that's from the last video we did so
go back watch that video and then watch
this video so you get it it's a callback
that's a callback to a different video
okay
I want y'all to be clear